- [Announcer] This UCSD-TV program is
presented by University of California
television. Like what you learn? Visit our
website or follow us on Facebook and
Twitter to keep up with the latest
programs.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape:
bipedal, naked, large brain. Long the
master of fire, tools and language, but
still trying to understand ourselves.
Aware that death is inevitable, yet filled
with optimism. We grow up slowly. We hand
down knowledge. We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our shared
understanding of the past. CARTA brings
together experts from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are and how
we got here. An exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Rob] So there's a tremendous amount of
excitement about the microbiome at the
moment in part due to the $173,000,000
dollar NIH Human Microbiome Project where
the results catapulted from the pages of
Science and Nature to the cover of
Scientific American to the cover of The
Economist in record time and into public
consciousness. How did the excitements
that we're finding due to the decline in
cost in DNA sequencing over a million-fold
in the last 15 years? The microbes do all
kinds of things that we never suspected.
For example, they determine how attractive
we are to mosquitoes. So you're not crazy
when you go camping. You might really be
10 times as attractive to mosquitoes as
the person you're camping with. They
determine how we respond to drugs. And
they even determine traits like obesity
and a wide range of other diseases have
subsequently been linked to the
microbiome. So a lot of what we're trying
to do at the moment is understanding how
can we map our microbes across our bodies
or across our planet? And the intuition is
here is that as you go to different parts
of the world, you see different species in
different locations that immediately
identify a scene that's coming from one
place or another or another. So with
microbes, it's more or less the same, but
we have the problem that they basically
look the same under a microscope, unlike
these charismatic mega-fauna [sp]. So
instead what we do is we turn to the DNA
to understand them. Now, the Human
Microbiome Project together with a team of
about 400 researchers across the country,
we collected about four and a half
trillion As, Ts, Gs and Cs. But then the
problem with the data is it looks like
this. So this is the first 0.1% of the
first file. There's another 17,000 of
these. It's pretty hard to tell who lives
where in the environment from that, right?
So what we do is we use computational
techniques to develop these kinds of
abstract maps where each point summarizes
all of the complexity in a given microbial
community summed up by its DNA. And two
points close together are more similar in
terms of the evolutionary history of their
microbes. Two that are further apart are
more dissimilar in their microbial
evolutionary history.
And so when we do this, we see
automatically emerging these major
patterns where the mouth is very different
from the skin, the vaginal microbiomes and
the fecal microbiome down the bottom there
is distinct yet again. And so what this
implies is that two samples from the same
person can be real different in terms of
the microbes. So here I'm highlighting one
oral sample and one fecal sample from the
first person with the Human Microbiome
Project. So these are pretty different on
this map, but we only really understood
this when we cross-referenced the data to
the Earth Microbiome Project where we can
go out into different physical
environments and ask what two samples are
as different from each other as the mouth
and the gut of this one person. And so, if
we compare your mouth to being kind of
like a coral reef, you have these complex
mineralized structures covered with
biofilms that maybe your dentist pesters
you about. The microbes in the gut are as
far away from the microbes in the mouth as
the microbes in this reef are from the
microbes in this prairie in Kansas; so
essentially, non-overlapping communities.
And what that means is that a few feet
along the length of your GI tract can make
as much difference to your microbes as
hundreds of miles across the Earth's
surface. And what I'll show you is that
the skin which is like yet another
microbial continent, has tremendous
diversity as well both within you as an
individual and between different people.
So this might lead you to wonder how
stable our microbiome is, at least if
we're healthy. And my partner, Amanda
who's--I've got her put up with a lot in
the name of microbiome research. And I
addressed this question by sampling our
own microbiomes every single day for a
period of six months. So when I project
that into a slightly simpler version of
this data frame, basically, the dark
points on this are me. The light points
are her. Now, what you can see when I
start this going, so each frame on this
animation is one day as we move through
this landscape in microbiomes defined by
different people. And you can see
immediately how the skin in blue is much
more variable even within one person than
the other sites. The mouth in green is the
most constant, and then the gut down at
the bottom is intermediate between the
two.
You can also see how we retain our
separate microbial identities through the
six-month period, and that's especially
remarkable when you consider we work
together and have all kinds of
opportunities to exchange microbes with
each other. I'll just rotate this around
so you can see how we retain those
separate microbial identities there. So
all of this might lead you to wonder where
do we get these personally unique microbes
from. And if you have dogs or kids as I
do, you probably have some dark suspicions
about that all of which are true by the
way. So it turns out I can actually match
you up to your dog by the microbes you
share. Now that's not to say that your
microbes are exactly the same as the
dog's. So here what we can see on a map
that includes both humans and dogs is that
every site of the body whether it's the
tongue, the stool, or the skin, the dog
and the human are separate from one
another. And again, you can see that the
dog's skin is very variable just like the
human skin is. But in all seriousness, our
first microbes depend tremendously on how
we're born. And so, this is like we did
with Maria Gloria Dominguez-Bello now at
NYU, looking at microbes of mothers now
before they gave birth and then of their
babies within 20 minutes of birth. And
what you can see in red is the vaginal
communities from the mothers and then in
pink, we have microbes from all over the
bodies including the skin and including
the gut of babies 20 minutes after they
were born. Whereas in contrast, in the
dark blue, we have all the skin
communities from the mothers. And in light
blue, we have all the habitats from all
over the body of babies delivered by
C-section. So what you can see is that if
you're delivered by C-section, you're
denied the vaginal microbes you would
ordinarily have as you pass through the
birth canal. We think that the lack of
that co-evolved microbial community may
explain some of the differences in health
between vaginally delivered and C-section
babies. Of course, the most likely outcome
if you have a kid by C-section is that
your kid will be fine, but there are
slightly somewhat higher risks of all
kinds of diseases including ectopic
dermatitis, food allergies and even
obesity, all of which have now been linked
to the microbiome.
So again with Maria Gloria, we're doing
this trial at the moment to try to figure
out, can you restore the microbial
community to kids delivered by C-section.
And so, what we're doing here is
essentially collecting the vaginal
microbes from mothers then delivering them
to the babies. And this is very
preliminary data at this point, but we are
able to show partial restoration of the
microbial community both in the gut and in
the skin by applying this procedure. And
so, we're hoping to develop this into a
large enough study to develop clinical
recommendations based on this microbial
restoration. So you might be wondering,
"Well, what happens after that?" What I'm
going to show you now is the trajectory of
one child--this is what we did with Ruth
Lee [sp], tracking one child over the
first two and a half years of life. And so
what we're going to be looking at his gut
community. He was delivered vaginally, and
you can see that his initial fecal sample
is up there in the vaginal region with
perhaps a little skin contribution as
well. And so the question is, "How long
does it take him to move through this
landscape towards the adult fecal
community over two and a half years? How
complete is that progression down towards
the bottom? And is it smooth or is it
chaotic?" So what you can see is at some
weeks, he changes a little bit whereas
other weeks, he changes a lot. And
remember what matters on these plots is
the distance from one point to another. So
it really is true that one week to the
next, your kid can look like a completely
different person at least when you compare
the distances between these points to the
distances between healthy adults in the
Human Microbiome Project which are those
points in brown at the bottom. Now, coming
up here is something fascinating. So he
gets antibiotics for the ear infection.
See that tremendous regression of the
microbiome and then the recovery. That
went by pretty fast, so I'm just going to
rewind it for you and play it again. So
what you can see is on administration of
oral amoxicillin for an ear infection, you
see this tremendous regression of the gut
microbiome and during months of normal
development, followed in this case, by
rapid recovery.
Then by the time he gets to two and a half
years, he's more or less in the healthy
adult distribution. But we just don't know
in general what the effects of antibiotics
are on the rest of the body and on the
sites they're targeted and whether those
early life changes can have profound and
lasting effects. There's some evidence in
both humans and experimental animal models
that early life antibiotics in the first
six months can lead to increased rates of
obesity, but we don't know about the
impact on the skin, on the mouth and on
other sites on the body yet. We can also
do this sort of thing cross-culturally. So
here in which we have gotten and we've got
an African population in red, South
American population in green and then the
US population in blue, the gut communities
converged on one another after the first
three years of life. However, where they
wound up in the three populations was very
different. So the rate of approach to the
adult stage is very similar
cross-culturally, but the final stage
where you end up can be very different.
And you can see the Western population in
that right-hand panel in blue is very
different from the two non-Western
populations. And in that respect, it's
important to remember that even
large-scale projects like the Human
Microbiome Project have largely only
looked at healthy Western adults. And as
soon as you start to go into children and
as soon as you start to go to non-Western
populations, you see very different
things. This is true not just in the gut,
but in every site in the body. So for
example, this is what we did with Maria
Gloria Dominguez looking at previously
uncontacted Yanomami in South America. And
what you can see is the Yanomami
population is more diverse in the skin, so
that's the left panel, than the US
population. And then the microbes that
they have on the skin are completely
different. So those green points separate
completely from the yellow points of the
US population.
So this might lead you to wonder, "Well,
we've seen that the skin can vary
cross-culturally, but how does it vary
over the human body?" And this is like
we've been doing with Pieter Dorrestein
here at UCSD in the Skaggs School of
Pharmacy. And across the skin, it's just
so fascinating. It's this interface
between ourselves and the physical
environment that we're in contact with. So
Pieter was interested in how microbes were
over the skin. So he recruited two
subjects one of which was him, and sampled
the skin at 500 sites over the body and
then analyzed each of those sites using
two kinds of mass spectrometry. And
re-sequenced the DNA of the bacteria to
give a readout of where they are all over
the body. And one thing that was
fascinating is that all of the microbes
can differentiate the two subjects from
one another. They're not nearly as
distinct subject to subject as the
metabolites are. So you can see that the
metabolites from these two completely
separate clouds, one from the male in blue
and one from the female in red. And so,
the metabolites we can track down where
they are in the body. And some of them are
broadly distributed all over the body.
Some are localized to the armpit or to the
groin or to the toenails or other
particular sites. And we can do the same
kind of thing for the microbes. So for
example, staphylococcus is mostly in the
moist regions like you'd expect so the
nose and feet. Propionibacterium are on
the head and shoulders and corynebacterium
broadly over the body. So one thing that
was really fascinating about this was when
we built these molecular networks to try
to figure out how the chemicals related to
one another, what we could see is that
most of the chemicals we found on human
skin did not come from pure bacterial
cultures or from human skin cell cultures,
but instead came from beauty products. And
in fact, 90% of chemicals that we
identified on skin in the study came from
sunscreen and moisturizer and shampoo and
other things that our subjects applied to
their bodies. So that's just fascinating,
right? That 90% of the identifiable
chemicals on your body probably come from
consumer products that you apply. So to
address this problem, I've been working
with the Hadza in Tanzania together with
Jeff Leach through the Human Food Project.
And so, these are people who have not been
exposed to any of these products at all.
And essentially, what we've been doing is
sampling a wide range of things there
including the gut, the skin, the various
dwellings and so forth on different
projects. And so what you can see is that
the Hazda, shown here in yellow, have very
different metabolic communities from the
Westerners even when we were out at the
field site. So we're at the same location,
but you see these very different skin
metabolite profiles. And what you can see
is of the metabolites that we saw, only
about 25% of what was identified was
shared by the Hadza skin and the skin of
Westerners. You can also see that the
Hadza skin is much closer to the
environmental samples, mostly water
samples that we collected on-site in green
there. They also have a fairly large
contribution from honey which can make up
a lot of their calories in the dry season
which is when we were doing the sampling.
And we can also see a number of plants
that are contributing to the Hadza and not
to the Westerner metabolites. And so these
are things like baobabs and other major
sources of food that we can track down the
specific metabolic links between the food
and the person. So this is a kind of
molecular network where essentially you
can think of this as basically being like
constellations of the different
metabolites where you connect up the ones
that are related to each other and match
them up to different kinds of
environmental samples. And so what we can
do with this is we can identify clusters
that their specific to particular niches.
So for example, we can see plant
flavonoids. We can see monostearate which
is more on the healthcare products in the
US population. And we can zoom in and for
example, look at the flavonoids and how
the profiles are somewhat similar, but
then with subtle differences between the
US and the Hadza individuals in the study.
And then similarly, we can do this sort of
thing with seterols which again are mostly
coming from plant metabolites and from
sucrose from the beehive which is found
predominantly in the Hadza. So we can also
do this sort of thing looking at the
bacteria. And what I'm doing here is just
coloring it by body site. So for example,
the green is stool. The pink is skin, and
you can see this tremendous heterogeneity
in the skin. And we also got some samples
from three collaborators at the Yerkes
Primates Center, and I'm just going to
make some of the balls bigger for the
chimpanzees. Those of you familiar with
chimpanzee anatomy will understand why.
And so, what you can see is that the fecal
samples from the chimps are distinct from
the fecal samples from the humans. Then
correspondingly, the few skin samples we
have from one chimpanzee individual, those
large pink balls, are substantially
distinct from the skin samples from any of
the humans including the Hadza. And then
within the human population like you can
see here basically the gray samples of
skin are samples from Westerners, and the
colored balls are from Hadza from
different camps. And you can see that
again, like the South American Yanomami
group I showed you before, the Hadza skin
samples are distinct from what we see in
Westerners. So we're just starting to
uncover the links between microbiology and
different lifestyles. I should point out
that most of this data from the Hadza and
from the chimpanzees was assembled over
the past week, and many of these figures
we made last night on the spot, so this is
still very preliminary data. We're still
trying to fully understand the results. So
anyway, one thing that's exciting about
matching up the metabolite and the
bacterial profiles is we can get an idea
of what bacteria are doing what functions.
So if I show you something like
proprionibacterium which is mostly on the
head and shoulders and then--sorry, mostly
on the head and shoulders and then
something like oleic acid which is on the
head and on the hands. You can see in the
third figure that oxidized oleic acid,
which is a metabolic product of oleic
acid, that's on the head where you see
proprionibacterium but not on the hands
where you don't see it.
And then similarly with palmitic acid, we
can see it getting degraded to monoolein,
monopalmitin only with proprionibacterium
mostly. So what we can do then is we can
test that hypothesis by taking the
bacteria cultured off skin, and then
incubating it with a precursor and just
verifying that that particular bacterium
in the lab can do the chemical reaction
that we attribute to it. Okay, so I'm just
going to talk very briefly about how we
exchange our skin microbes with our
environment. And for example, we can match
up the keys on your computer keyboard to
the tips of your fingers and the palm of
your hand with your computer mouse with up
to 95% accuracy based on the microbes you
share. So this came out in the scientific
journal PANS a few years ago. Here, I'm
just showing you the skin of the
fingertips from the keyboard keys
clustering together by subject for three
different people. But more importantly, it
was on the TV show, CSI: Miami so you
really know it's true. In any case, we can
use this kind of mapping technique towards
sources of pathogens in the kitchen where
you can see in that top panel that you're
leaving your skin communities primarily on
the door handles and the trash can and
other things that you touch. We can do the
same kind of thing in bathrooms. So here
you can see that the skin's mostly on the
door handles and the toilet seats. Our
stool's fortunately mostly confined to the
bathroom. Then there's a big signal from
soil on the floor and intriguingly also on
the flush handle where apparently, a lot
of people were using their feet to flush.
And coming from New Zealand, I had never
heard of this cultural practice, but
apparently it's fairly common in the US.
We can also do the same sort of thing in
homes. So this is what we did with Jack
Gilbert looking at what happens when you
move into a new house, and you can imagine
some different scenarios. So for example,
you might stay the same, and the house
might stay the same.
You might unpack your microbes all over
the house with the rest of your
belongings. Maybe the house instead
contributes microbes to you, or finally,
maybe you and the house blend into a new
community state. One thing we saw was that
the house microbes were very highly
correlated with human microbes from the
same dwelling. There was one case where
there were two lodgers--sorry, where there
was a couple and a lodger, and to
everyone's immense relief, the two people,
the couple were more similar to one
another in their microbial community than
either was to the lodger. And so there was
no difficult explaining to do. But one
thing we can do is we can track the
individual contribution to different
surfaces. So here what we're looking at is
each individual and each dog's
contribution to different surfaces like
the bathroom doorknob, the bedroom floor
and so. You can see that black line.
That's where person one went away on a
trip, and you can see their particular
contribution to all of these surfaces
disappearing during that period when
they're away. So we can even tell who's
inhabiting a particular space by the
microbes that they're leaving behind. But
more seriously, we can apply this sort of
thing in the hospital environment to where
the hospital acquired infections. And we
can also apply these techniques to really
compelling questions in animal health. So
for example in the Earth Microbiome
Project, we've been looking at a huge
number of different microbial samples so
over 30,000 samples provided to them by
members of the community. And for example,
looking at komodo dragons--so this is me
swabbing a baby komodo dragon at the
Denver zoo called Bintang. What we can see
is that each komodo dragon in their
enclosure shares a whole lot of microbes
with the particular enclosure it's in just
like we do as humans with the enclosures
in which we capture ourselves. But what's
fascinating is that the microbial
communities of the captive komodo dragon's
soil don't resemble at all the communities
that we see in soil in the wild. So you
see these two completely distinct clouds
of points. And what's interesting is the
degree of sharing is pretty similar to the
degree of sharing we see between humans
and pets in the same houses, but not the
degree of sharing that we see with wild
amphibians and their environment where a
constant input of microbes seems to be
really important for health.
Speaking of amphibian health, one thing
that's really important is this fungal
disease called Bd which is leading to
amphibian declines worldwide. And one
thing that's fascinating--and this is with
Val McKenzie at Boulder--is that we can
look at a whole lot of different
amphibians and actually put them along
this axis of resistance from the least
resistant to the most resistant to Bd
based on the skin microbial community. And
then the really cool part is like Rich
showed you in humans, we can actually
transfer the microbes from one frog to
another and confer resistance to the skin
fungus. And so, this idea of microbial
transplants is turning out to be
incredibly compelling. So I'll just wrap
up very briefly by mentioning that you can
put yourself on these kinds of microbial
maps now through this project called
American Gut, that will also accept skin
and other samples. And not everyone wants
to know what's in there, these middle
schoolers reacting to the idea we're going
to use robots and lasers to look at their
poop. But just to re-orient you on the map
in cases like clostridium difficile, what
you can see is this extreme dysbiotic
microbial community if you have this
profound form of diarrhea where you're
going to the bathroom many times a day. I
just want to show you what happens when
you do ecosystem restoration where you
have one donor who's down on the healthy
state there and transmit that to four
patients. So this is with Mike Sadowsky
and Alex Khoruts of the University of
Minnesota. And what you can see is that on
transmission of that microbiome from the
healthy donor to the four of these
patients, and each frame on this is just
going to be one day in the life of the
microbiome. What you can see is
essentially immediately, they go from the
unhealthy stage into the healthy stage,
and then they stay there. And so the
prospects to do this kind of thing--and
this is [inaudible 00:24:08] to clinical
remission of their symptoms within a day
or two.
The ability to do this sort of thing in
all body habitats whether it's the gut or
the skin or elsewhere is an incredibly
compelling area of medicine today given
the large number of diseases we now know
are linked to the microbiome. But what we
really have to do is develop not just
these microbial maps, but the kind of
microbial GPS that tells you not just
where are you right now but where do you
want to go in terms of your microbiome,
and what do you need to do step by step in
order to get there. We need to develop
this and make it so easy to use that even
our children can use it. So you can
imagine the kind of smart toilet that's
going to do an analysis of your microbes
and your metabolites. It's going to
deliver it to your smartphone which, let's
face it, I bet you're using it in there
anyway. And it's going to tell you whether
you're going in a good direction or a bad
direction and maybe what, specifically,
you need to do in order to improve the
health of any of your microbiomes whether
it's your gut or your skin. So with that,
I'll briefly thank again the many people
who contributed to the specific week I
showed you, the large number of amazing
people I've had working with me in my lab
currently and formerly, and finally,
thanks for your attention.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Mark] I first got interested in lice
many years ago when my now 25-year-old son
was in elementary school and he came home
with one of those fliers saying that one
of the kids in his class had genital lice
and what sorts of things parents should be
on the lookout for. Also included was a
flier with a bunch of what I refer to as
fun facts about human lice that I didn't
know about. These includes the facts that
our lice only parasitize humans. They
don't live on cats or dogs or your other
pets. You don't have to worry about
picking it up from them or transferring
them to your pets. In other words, this
means they're obligate parasite of humans.
They can only live on human hosts.
Secondly, they can't survive more than
about 24 hours away from the human body.
That means they can't take up residence in
your bedding or your clothing or except,
you know, be infected from that source. I
thought, well if this is true, then what
that means is that the spread of lice
around the world must have been
accomplished by the spread of humans
around the world. And since human
migrations is something that I'm
interested in, that maybe by studying
lice, we can learn something more about
human migrations. Then, a few years later
when I actually had time to start looking
into this in more detail, I found out that
was actually potentially even more
interesting because us humans, we like to
think about what and look into what makes
us special, what makes us different from
other creatures. One of the things that
makes us unique, as far as I know, in the
animal world, is that we were the only
species parasitized by three different
types of lice. Lice are ubiquitous. All
mammals have lice, birds have lice, fish
have lice, but we alone have three
different types of lice. Two of these,
that I'll talk about, start out, and then
mention the third one later, are the head
louse, pediculus capitis, and the body
louse, pediculus humanus, or sometimes
also classified as a subspecies of
pediculus capitis. As you can see,
morphologically, they look quite similar.
What actually differentiates them is their
ecology. The head louse, as the name
suggests, lives and feeds exclusively on
the human scalp. Body louse feeds on the
body but actually lives in the clothing
and lays its eggs in clothing. Now you ask
yourself, how would this difference come
about? Why would we have two different
kinds of lice that do these two different
things? The answer that seems to make the
most sense is that this ecological
difference between head and body louse
probably arose when clothing became
important in human evolution. Then, it
became available as a new niche, a new
ecological niche that lice can move into
and start exploiting and start adapting
to. It evolved to become body lice. If
that's true, if you buy that, what we can
do is use a molecular clock approach and
we can date the origin of body lice, the
divergence between head and body lice. By
inference, that tells us when clothing
became important in human evolution. Will
we need to do the molecular clock? Well
the molecular clock is a long-standing
idea in evolutionary genetics and it goes
back to the idea that the rate of
evolution, the rate of change of DNA
sequences is approximately constant over
time. This idea is supported by a good
deal of observation. You take pairs of
species where you have some idea when they
diverge from fossil to bio-geographic
evidence, you measure the amount of DNA
divergence between them and you plot that,
and you see very strong and astonishingly
close correlation between how much
divergence there is in DNA sequences and
how long ago those two species last shared
a common ancestor. It's also supported by
theory, but I'll skip over the gory
details of that. So what do we need in
order to use a molecular clock approach?
Well, we need a calibration point. We need
to know how fast the clock is ticking. We
need to know what is the rate of change in
our DNA sequences. What we did, in order
to do this, is we assume that when
chimpanzees and humans diverged, chimps
being the the closest living relative of
humans, so did their lice.
The idea that when hosts diverge, their
parasites also diverge is this
co-evolution between host and parasites. A
long standing observation biology. There
are certainly many exceptions to it, but
by and large, it is the rule. When host
speciate so do their spare parasites. We
therefore, can get an idea of how fast the
clock is ticking, if we can take
chimpanzee lice, compare them to human
lice, measure their DNA differentiation,
and we assume that differentiation
occurred about six million years ago.
Well, that then gives us our calibration,
that tells us how fast the clock is
ticking. In addition to do this work, we
need our lice samples. We got head lice
and body lice from all different sources
around the world. Not everyone was pleased
to hear from us and sometimes, we got
rather indignant responses about how dare
we suggest they might have lice at their
facility. But nonetheless, we got a good
worldwide sample of lice. We also got
chimpanzee lice, pediculus schaeffi from
the chimp sanctuary in Uganda. What is
also very important, since we have no clue
as to what these things are actually
supposed to look like, we had a local
expert examine them and confirm that the
identifications are indeed correct. Then,
what we did was we obtained DNA sequences
from these lice. We obtained two
mitochondrial DNA gene sequences which
gave the same results when analyzed
separately so we combine them, analyze
them together. Also, just to make sure
that there wasn't something strange about
the mitochondrial DNA, we obtained and
analyzed sequences of two nuclear genes.
Then, we did a couple of sanity checks to
make sure that the results we were
getting, they're corresponding to what we
might expect. One who things we looked at
was a genetic diversity in the African
lice versus the non-African lice. What you
can see is that all of these genes have
different amounts of diversity which is
what we always observe because the amount
of diversity in a gene is a reflection of
the functional constraints on that gene,
but what we also see is that for each
gene, there's more diversity in the
African lice than in the non-African lice.
Greater diversity implies that's where the
source is, that's where the origin is
because you had the most time, you
accumulate the most diversity. That's good
because what this indicates is that
greater diversity in African lice implies
an African origin of human lice. And since
that's where we think humans arose, that's
a good sanity check. The other check we
did on this is to compare the head lice
and the body lice. Again, you can see for
each of these three genes more diversity
in the head lice than in the body lice.
That fits with the scenario I told you
about that body lice are more recent in
origin than the head lice. They've had
less time to accumulate diversity. Now we
can do a phylogenetic analysis, putting
together all of these lice sequences using
the chimpanzee louse as an outgroup. The
Hs are the head lice, the Bs are the body
lice, the numbers in parenthesis are the
numbers of individual lice that had that
particular sequence. When we apply the
molecular clock approach, we see that the
clay here that contains all of the body
lice sequences as well as some of the head
lice sequences has an age of about 70,000
years ago, give or take, a few tens of
thousands of years. What we can also see
in this tree is that there is a particular
clay there which contains all of the body
lice as well as some of the head lice
sequences which has lots and lots of
little short branches. And that's a
signature of a population expansion. But
we also see in this analysis is evidence
for a population expansion occurring in
lice around this time. The conclusion we
came up with, from the study, is that body
lice arose about 70,000 years ago, which
then implies that that's when clothing
became important in human evolution,
provided the niche for the body lice to
start diverging. Now, how does this
compare to archaeological evidence
concerning the origin of clothing? Well,
clothing itself doesn't fossilize, so what
we have to do is rely on indirect
evidence.
If we look at the indirect evidence, stone
tools and bone tools, that would be
unequivocally associated with clothing;
things, like needles for example. Those
are on the order of about 40,000 years old
at the most. Now, there are certainly
other tools around like scrapers that
potentially could have been used to
prepare hides for clothing by scraping
them off, but they also could be used for
other purposes. We don't really know for
sure what all they were being used for.
The overall conclusion is if we look at
the archaeological evidence, it does not
contradict a fairly recent origin of
clothing, only about on the order of
70,000 years ago or so. To summarize the
results of this study, we see that body
lice originated from head lice, again
70,000 years ago or so. We see that
there's also population expansion that
occurred in lice at right around this
time. While this is all very speculative,
what is very tempting to try to relate
this to is the expansion of modern humans
out of Africa which is been dating
directly in DNA evidence in humans to be
between 50 and 100 thousand years ago.
Both suggest that perhaps is when humans
expanded out of Africa, began growing in
size, developed clothing and that this
clothing became available as a niche for
the origin of the body lice. What about
Neanderthals? Whenever you work with
modern humans, sooner or later, someone
will ask you, "Well what about
Neanderthals?" What does this tell us
about Neanderthals and other archaic
humans? Did they have clothing? Well, this
is what we think are the evolutionary
relationships of modern humans and
neanderthals. They shared a common
ancestor 600,000 years ago, give or take a
few tens of thousands of years. Clothing,
if we believe the lice results, originated
sometime here around the dispersion of
modern humans out of Africa. This would
suggest one of two possibilities for
Neanderthals. Either they did not have
clothing, or if they did have clothing
they invented it independently of modern
humans.
In other words, they did not inherit
clothing from a common ancestor of
Neanderthals and modern humans. Now,
there's nothing in what we can infer from
the cognitive abilities of Neanderthals,
based on the archaeological record and so
forth, that would suggest that they were
just too stupid to come up with the idea
of clothing, right? Certainly, quite
feasible, they would have come up with the
idea of clothing on their own, invented it
independently from modern humans. It
certainly is the case that if you look at
reconstruction of Neanderthals, they're
almost always shown in having clothing.
Something like this. There's another
potential view about what Neanderthals
were like. Maybe, they were more like
this. Now, this is a pretty terrible
reconstruction of a Neanderthal from most
perspectives, but I show it here because
it shows neanderthals as having body hair,
as having retained their body hair. That
brings up the question, "Well when did we
actually lose body hair during our
evolutionary history?" We have no clue
about that from fossil evidence, and
modern genetics so far has not been able
to come up with that answer. When did we
lose body hair? If we lost body hair
recently maybe Neanderthals still had body
hair. Maybe then, therefore, when they
moved out of Africa into the colder
climates, they didn't need clothing
because they already their body hair.
There's lots of other mammals that moved
out of Africa at the same time. They
didn't invent clothing. They got along
perfectly well without. That brings up the
question, when did we lose our body hair?
A potential answer from that comes from
the third type of lice that we have.
That's this lovely creature here. This is
a public louse. Pubic lice, as the name
suggests, they live and feed exclusively
in the pubic region. As I've already told
you, the head lice live and feed
exclusively on the scalp. Now, you ask
yourself, how would this difference come
about between these two different types of
lice. The answer that seems to make sense
is that at one time we had body hair, we
had hair all over us, we had one type of
lice then we lost body hair so that we
only have hair in the pubic region and in
the head region. Now, we have a barrier
that the lice can't cross. We have
geographic isolation, we get classic
allopatric speciation, and now we have our
two types of lice.
Well, again, if you buy that, then we can
use the molecular clock approach and ask,
"When did the difference between public
and head lice occur?" and date that
divergence. That might tell us something
about when humans, then lost their body
hair. Now, that all sounds very nice and
neat, however, it's not quite that simple.
Life is never that simple. Here's the view
of lice evolution that I just told you
about. Going back as far as the gorilla
lineage. Gorilla lineage branched off
before the chimpanzee and the human
lineages. If we start with the gorilla
lineage, we have a common ancestor,
gorillas, chimps, and humans. The gorilla
lineage branches off that leads to the
evolution of gorilla louse. Chimp lineage
branches off, that leads to the
differentiation of chimp lice and the
origin of all human lice. We then have
loss of body hair, that leads to the
origin of the pubic louse and finally, we
have clothing and that leads to the origin
of the body louse separate from the head
louse. That looks all very reasonable,
however, the complication is that the
taxonomy, classical taxonomy, of lice does
not agree with this. The classical
taxonomy looks at things this way. Body
louse, in the genus pediculus as I told
you, as is the head louse, as is the
chimpanzee louse, but the pubic louse is
put into a different genus by the
taxonomists, the genus phthirus. That is
the same genus as the gorilla louse. I
will refrain from any speculation as to
how humans might have gotten pubic lice
from gorillas, but one possibility is that
the taxonomy based on morphology is wrong.
There are many examples we know where
taxonomy based on morphology differs from
that based on the DNA.
Clearly, what we need is DNA evidence to
see what's going on here and we also need
DNA from gorilla lice to see what's going
on here. David Reed's group at Florida did
just that and found out that lo and
behold, the taxonomy is recorded by the
DNA. You get the same picture from the
DNA. When did this divergence between
human public lice and gorilla lice occur?
About 3.3 million years ago. If you
believe that this colonization, this
transfer, from gorillas to humans would
have occurred only after humans would have
lost their body hair, which I think is
probably the most reasonable scenario,
then that would suggest that body hair
loss occurred relatively early on in human
evolution, not too long after the
divergence from the chimp lineage which
fits with some other ideas that people
have had about loss of body hair. It would
appear that our ancestors do have some
explaining to do with this. To conclude,
genetic analyses of head and body lice do
indicate that clothing became important
somewhere around 70,000 years ago, seems
to coincide with the expansion of modern
humans out of Africa, maybe had something
to do with that expansion. Genetic
analyses of pubic lice suggest our
ancestors had lost their body hair by
roughly 3, 3.3 million years ago, not so
long after the divergence from
chimpanzees, so it was relatively early
on. On with the acknowledgments, I
especially want to single out Ralf
Kittler, Manfred Kayser, the two people in
my group who did the work we've done on
lice, and all these other people for
contributing samples not necessarily their
own lice samples of course. And the Max
Planck Society for funding all of our
work. Thank you for your attention.
♪ [music] ♪
- [Christopher] I'm going to start with a
family photo. This is my niece, Allison.
She's about seven years old. And this is
also my niece, Allison, right after birth.
So what's going on here? There's something
very unusual about our species, right? We
take it for granted that our newborns come
out with a very large amount of body fat
under the skin, or subcutaneous fat. We
even have a name for it; baby fat, and we
consider it a mark of health. But this is
actually a very unusual characteristic. If
you look across other species, like
gorilla for instance, they come out
skinny. Here's a baboon, also very skinny.
Almost 20 years ago, I compiled all the
information I could about body fat and
newborns, and published a paper
on it. And this is what I found. These
species here, as you can see, are all
about 3% body fat or less at birth. And
this includes species like elephant,
seals, black bear, pigs, so typical
mammals. Over here you have harp seals,
guinea pigs, and the very fattest species
that I could find evidence for was us, at
about 15% body fat. Now preparing for this
talk, I went into the literature and tried
to find any more data points that had been
published, especially on primates. Notice
here that the only primate that I could
find was a baboon, at about 3%. We have
some more data points now. We have
macaques, squirrel monkeys, another
species of macaques all have less than 3%.
Over here on the left you will see that
there is a new species that I found that
is actually a little bit fatter than us,
it seems. But there are only two
individuals in that sample and they are
clinical. They are a clinical sample, not
a wild sample. We will see how that shakes
out, but it really does not fundamentally
change the story. It is pretty clear that
this is an unusual characteristic for us.
We are born with a lot of body fat and not
only that... Look at body fat development
post-natally. What this shows is skinfold
thickness. This is how you measure the
thickness of the subcutaneous fat. You
take a skinfold and you literally measure
it with a caliper.
This is the average here, this red line,
within the population. You see that we are
born with a lot of fat, but then right
after birth we put lots of calories into
putting on more fat. Our fat actually
peaks out during the first year of life.
And then it declines until that very low
point that I showed you earlier, in mid
childhood. The question that I want to
pose today is, why are our newborns so
unusually fat and yet our children are so
lean? Before getting into this, I want to
dispel one myth that you will find out
there. If you look at old pediatrics text
books, there is this idea that yes, this
is an unusual characteristic for our
species. Perhaps it is insulation because
we lost hair. We lost our hair and we need
this insulatory layer of blubber to
compensate for that. There is a lot of
evidence against that. Sounds like a neat
idea, but we don't have any evidence that
humans preferentially deposit fat under
the skin. What happens is the more fat you
put on the more fat you get under the
skin. It is a good place to put it. There
is nothing that suggests that we have
anatomically adapted ourselves for that
kind of insulatory layer. There are human
populations that live in the high Arctic,
places like Alaska and so forth, where you
see biological adaptations to conserve
heat. You see shorter limbs and you see
shorter stature. What this does is it
reduces skin surface area and reduces heat
loss. In this populations you see no
evidence for thicker skin folds, in fact
they tend to have slightly thinner skin
folds than the temperate populations.
Finally, you can look at newborns and see
studies that have done this to try to
figure out what it is that predicts
thermal stability. It is not the skin fold
thicknesses that matter. It seems to be
the muscle mass, which is where the heat's
being generated. I didn't find a lot of
evidence to support this idea that this
excessive amount of subcutaneous fat,
especially in our newborns, is related to
insulation. So I've proposed a different
idea, a competing idea. The key to
understanding our unusually fat babies may
lie in another unique human trait, our
unusually large and energetically costly
brains.
The idea here is that if you have a large
and energetically costly brain, you're
going to need, effectively, a bigger
battery to back it up during a period of
shortage. That's the idea I want to dig
into today. We're going to explore, we're
going to talk a bit about the human brain,
its energetic costs, and why we need a
bigger energy backup. Then I'm going to
tell you about some new work that some
collaborators and I published last year
that quantifies the cost of the brain
across the life cycle, from birth onward.
Finally, we're going to bring all this
together with some other information and
try to make sense of this pattern of fat
development that we see in humans. Let's
start with this first point. We're a
brainy species. The last four million
years, as you see here, you see a lot of
increase in brain size. As I've already
alluded to, this is important
energetically because brain is costly
tissue. A gram of adult brain uses about
15 times the energy of a gram of muscle.
All of you sitting here right now are
adults, your body is putting off heat at
about 100 watts. That's the amount of heat
you're generating, warming up the room.
Twenty of those watts or 20% of your
resting metabolic rate is accounted for by
the brain. That may not seem that
impressive. It may even seem a little dim,
but if you compare us to other species,
you'll see that that's actually pretty
remarkable. All these species up here are
in the order of 2 to 3% of resting
metabolic rate goes to the brain. Here you
see there's a couple primate species,
spider monkeys and chimpanzees, at about
10%, and then human adults are at 20%. If
you look at a newborn of course, the size
of the head is so much larger compared to
the body, so that number is going to be a
lot bigger in the newborn. Sure enough, in
the old literature, the estimate had been
that 60% of the resting metabolism is
necessary just to keep the brain going.
This is important. It's not only just
costly, but it has other ramifications,
because unlike other tissues and organs
you can't turn the brain down. You can't
dim it. Let's say that you're starving or
under nutritional stress, the brain has a
constant metallic rate whether you're
sleeping, active, what have you. It has to
be maintained. Without access to that
energy you get brain damage.
Naturally, it makes sense that we need to
have a bigger energy backup. You can think
of an analogy from day to day life that I
think illustrates this. That would be a
mortgage. Every month, if you have a house
and you have a house mortgage, you have to
pay that mortgage. If you don't you have
to foreclose. If you lose your job, you'd
better have money in your savings account
in order to cover that mortgage for the
period you are unemployed. The bigger your
mortgage, the bigger the savings account
you're going to
need to have to avoid a foreclosure. It's
the same sort of logic. Effectively, our
newborns have a mortgage that accounts for
60% of their budget, so they need to have
a very big savings account. Maybe this
gives us some insights into what's going
on at birth, but we also have to
understand why we become so lean by
childhood. We set up both of this
problems. Maybe it's the change in the
size of that mortgage that matters. Let's
go ahead and start to look at that. What
this shows here is the percentage of body
weight that's accounted for by the brain
at different ages in humans. At birth, as
you can see, it's about 12% of body
weight. Then it declines as that ratio of
brain size to body size also declines.
Perhaps we need this big energy buffer
back here because our brains really
dominate the budget, but down here less
so. Maybe that's what's going on.
Unfortunately, it's not that simple
because all we're looking at in that last
graph is the size of the brain. There are
other factors to take into account. Energy
used by a gram of brain is actually very
dynamic very development and this relates
to the high cost of learning during
childhood. What makes the brain costly is
synapses, that is, the connections between
nerves. The number of synapses changes
very dramatically. Let's take a look at
that. These are classic data on synaptic
densities. This is telling us how many
synapses there are, how many neural
connections there are within a gram of
brain. You can see that it goes way up
quickly after birth, peaks out during
childhood, and then it declines again.
There's a process of pruning. This entire
period of very high synaptic connectivity
is all about learning during childhood.
What it means from our perspective is that
there's a need for energy to buoy that
excess neuronal activity. So how does one
go about measuring that energy? Well,
positron emission tomography imaging, PET
imaging, is one way you could do this.
This is what allows you to measure the
rate of glucose uptake in the brain. Harry
Chugani, in a classic paper from 1987 that
I'm showing here, did this in kids from
birth all the way up to adulthood. You can
see these folks over here on the right,
are the adults. So this dotted line is the
adult level of glucose uptake. At birth,
each gram of brain tissue is using about
30% less glucose than the adult brain.
That's because the synapses haven't
proliferated yet. Then by
childhood, it's actually twice the adult
rate, so it's much higher. Then you get
the pruning and it prunes down to the
adult level eventually. What we need to
really take into account what's going on
with the brain, is not just to account for
the size of the brain. But we also need to
take into account this changing energy
density, this changing energy use rate
related to learning. This is actually
something that I and my collaborators in
Northwestern University, at Wayne State,
and at George Washington University set
out to do. We published a paper on this
last year. I'm going to tell you what we
did, very quickly. We started with
Chugani's pet data, which I've already
shown you. That tells us how much glucose
each gram of brain is using. To get the
global cost of the brain, we need to know
how many grams of brain there are. For
that, we used brain volume data from MRI.
You do the numbers and you get total brain
energy cost. There are many more steps
involved, but that's a simplified version.
When you do that, this is what we find.
This shows brain glucose uptake from birth
until 15 years of age. Fifteen years is
the last PET measurements, that's where we
stopped.
You can see that it peaks out at about
five years of age. It's higher in males
because they're just bigger. There's no
real biological difference there. There's
a remarkable story here. Brain glucose
uptake at five years of age is about twice
the adult level. You can see this dotted
line here. Their brains are using twice
the energy of the adult brain, despite the
fact that their brains haven't fully
reached adult size yet, and despite the
fact that their bodies are one-third the
size. This is a remarkable burden on their
bodies, energetically. That's what we want
to take into account. Let's look at the
next step here. Instead of looking at
grams of glucose, let's consider brain
energetics as a fraction of the resting
metabolic rate, like we did earlier. When
we do it that way, we see that it's
peaking out at about four to five years of
age again. And at that point, two-thirds
of all resting calories are going to the
brain, which is pretty remarkable. This
leaves only one-third of the calories to
do everything else. So clearly, some other
functions must have been short-changed in
us. One of those functions that did get
short-changed, it looks like, was body
weight growth. What this shows here is the
rate of body weight gain. As we all know,
infants grow very quickly, and then the
rate of weight gain slows down. They start
to grow quite slowly by age five or so, or
during childhood. You almost don't see
them growing. You notice their development
but you don't see them getting bigger and
bigger. Then, gradually, weight gain takes
off again with puberty. Let's superimpose
the brain energetics curve on that.
There's pretty clearly a nice relationship
between these two. As the brain becomes
increasingly costly, because of brain
growth and the proliferation of those
costly synapses, body weight growth is
going down. When the brain is at its most
costly, body weight growth is at its
lowest. And then it reverses with puberty.
So clearly, there is something very
interesting going on here. It looks like
one of the ways that we were able to
support these very high energetic costs
related to brain development is by taking
calories that would have gone into growth
and putting them into the brain. So we're
kind of subsidizing that.
One of the things that suffers from that
is fat stores. That's why we have such low
adiposity during this era, because we're
basically shutting down growth and we're
shutting down fat deposition. This leads
to a bit of a paradox in what would appear
to be a challenge for a hypothesis. We've
got the age of lowest energy reserves,
when our savings account is at its lowest,
coinciding with the age when our mortgage
is at its highest. This looks very
precarious. Doesn't this potentially pose
a problem for a hypothesis? If baby fat is
a brain battery, how can body fat reach
its lowest level at the age when the
brain's energy needs are greatest. The
answer is, you don't necessarily need a
large savings account if you've got
wealthy relatives and friends who are
willing to lend to you. That's what goes
on. Let's take a look at this. As children
grow and develop they shift from relying
on their onboard energy buffer, their body
fat, to social buffering. The
effectiveness of social buffering
increases and as that happens, the
reliance on body fat goes down. We're
going to take a look at this. Let's start
early on, when there's this high reliance
on body fat as we've already talked about.
Why do we rely on body fat early? The
reason is this; because of the cause of
nutritional stress. Early in life, the
main causes of nutritional stress are
infectious disease. Forget about the
common cold. Think about environments that
are less sanitized than ours. Infections
can be quite severe. This is really the
cause of, for instance, under-five
mortality, infant mortality. It's all
about under nutrition and most of it is
driven by infection. It's easy to see why.
Kids when they get sick, they get
anorexia. They stop eating. Diarrheal
diseases are very common in infancy. This
impairs digestion. Your parents and your
caregivers can have all the calories and
the food in the world, but if you stop
eating and you don't digest, you're not
going to get access to them. Which forces
you to go internal and rely on your on
onboard energy reserves. That's really the
only strategy that you have.
Add on top of this, fever that actually
increases your energy expenditure and sort
of makes the whole thing worse. That's the
point. The common symptoms related to
infections, cut the baby off from
caregivers and force a reliance internally
on their own battery. Here we see the age
trends in diarrheal illness, globally. And
you see that it really peaks out in late
infancy and the second half of the first
year. This coincides with weaning and the
introductions of foods that are often not
sterile. Newborns are born without
antibodies which is why they get sick so
much. Every time they get sick, they
acquire antibodies and they become more
and more protected moving forward. As
infants age, they acquire these protective
antibodies, and the infections then
plummet. They're really not a problem by
four to five years of age, or not as much.
As those infections go down, they're no
longer being cut off from their caregivers
and they can start to benefit from the
unique features of the way we raise our
kids. I'm going to talk about that. It'll
be the last point we talk about. If we
look at other mammals, food comes from the
mother, breast milk. Eventually you get
weaned and you self-provision. In our
species, fathers are a part of the
picture, both in terms of provisioning and
care, but there's a whole cast of other
characters. This is something fairly
unique to us. We're considered cooperative
breeding species because many individuals
are involved in raising our kids.
Importantly, those human caregivers, in
turn, are embedded with the networks based
on cooperation and food sharing. Let's
take a look at this. Here's an example
where there are four hunters that are not
sharing. The second individual down has a
kill and the others don't, so they go
hungry. On this day, the first individual
has a kill, but the others go hungry, and
so on. It's kind of a feast/famine
scenario. Here's the same scenario where
this individual shares with other folks
under the assumption that they're going to
share with him when they have a kill. In
this kind of system, with food sharing,
everybody gets to eat every day. You don't
have the feast/famine. This is what we do.
If you look at data from hunter/gatherer
societies like the Hiwi and the Ache from
lowland Amazon in South America, this
shows the number of families that receive
part of the kill. This is very common.
Food flows between families. Here's an
other interesting study that was done
among the Hadza. Here, the individuals
were given honey sticks. There was an
economic game and the researchers
evaluated how honey flowed through the
society. As you can see, it's flowing all
over the place to both genetic kin, to
in-laws and to friends. If somebody up
here comes up short one day, there's going
to be food coming from elsewhere. Our
caregivers, there are not only multiple
caregivers taking care of our kids, but
they're embedded in these networks of
cooperation of food sharing which buffer.
It's for this reason, I think, that we can
go out on a limb as children. Our children
go way out on a limb, because they're
maxing out the size of their mortgage at a
point when the have a minimal savings
account. They can do it because they're
embedded within those networks. To
summarize and come back to where I began,
our babies are born with a lot of fat. The
reasons for this are that they have
extremely high energy requirements for
their brains that are fragile, combined
with the fact that the primary cause of
nutritional stress at this age is
infection, which cuts them off from
caregivers and forces a reliance on
internal stores. The situation's very
different by childhood. The brain is even
more costly, but now they're embedded
within, and benefit from that social
buffering that's so effective. They no
longer need to put those calories away in
a savings account. They can use them for
things that matter at this age; learning
and child development. That's all. Thanks.
♪ [music] ♪